hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game uh from the hainan danjou
grand master tournament that was played
in 2016. uh it's a game between peter
leko and yani ponishi
a lot of you have been asking me to show
some nipple games says nipple is the new
challenger to magnus cross and they will
play a match for the world chess
championship title in november
and i decided to show you some of his
more notable games such as this one as
this one is a
is a complete madness i decided to start
with this one
since peter leko is uh one of those
incredibly strong players that's
incredibly difficult to beat and
just beating him is a brilliancy in
itself and beating him in great style
well that's just
uh you know a whole other thing
so uh without further ado let's check it
out and then we're gonna
discuss you know stuff a little bit i
would just like to show you one thing as
uh something a lot of you are requesting
uh these
are the uh well this is the lifetime
record between nepo and the magnus so in
classical games uh yanni poncho has
defeated
magnus four to one uh with six draw so
uh the the depending on the format of
the wheelchair championship match
whether it's gonna be 12 or 16 classic
games uh this could go uh very well in
jan's favor however including uh
rapid and exhibition games magnus
defeated dion 20 to 10
uh so only rapid and exhibition game so
uh if the classical
one uh is decided in the draw then
magnus will could have the upper upper
hand
although these are only uh standings uh
prior to this match uh
here nepo will be the most prepared he
was ever
in any of the game or match i mean this
is the world church championship match
so it's a very hard to even speculate on
on
what to expect but this is one of the
games that i decided to start with
so let's check it out and let's see what
carlson might expect uh in in november
so let's go with the white pieces opens
with d4
sorry uh with e4 uh we have c5 young
opts for the sicilian defense we have
knight to f3 at d6 and
now d4 striking in the center so nothing
out of the ordinary here
captures capture so knight f6 knight the
c3 and a6 so a normal neither of
sicilian
is on the board and here f3 preparing
the standard setup bishop e3 queen d2
maybe some h4g4 ideas in the future
we have e5 by nippo pushing the knight
back now the knight has been retreated
to some other
squares are other than b3 92 knight f5
have been played but with very little
success and very few times and not not
in serious games so knight b3 is
uh well do you go to move here we have
bishop to e6 and bishop to e3 so both
players just nicely continued developing
bishop to e7 and now queen to d2
the queen bishop battery is is fully
operational and
the white king is raised to castle queen
side so here the
mostly played uh move for black is just
castles here but nipple decides to wait
with castles and pushes h5
uh which will be useful in the future to
prevent white from uh
starting to expand early with with some
h4g4 ideas
so bishop to e2 and now knight b to d7
uh we have knight to d5 ian still uh is
waiting with with the castling uh so
this knight
belongs on on the five c4 will be played
at some point
uh to really cement that piece on the e5
and here
uh while just capturing with the the
knight definitely makes sense and this
is what
uh usually people play here for example
just captures captures and bishop to f5
uh nipple again goes for the
less played idea bishop captures on the
e5 he gives up the bishop pair early on
for some very interesting play so
captures with the pawn on d5
and only now he castles kingside uh
leko also castles king side and now you
have to uh
start developing your queen and your
rooks and how do you do this the problem
with the normal developing move like
rook the c8
is that white has this knight to a5 move
and here that that's a problem for black
because
how are you defending the b7 pawn uh if
you push it
then the knight can come to c6 and this
is a this is just terrible for black
and if you try something like queen to
c7 to help defending it
like this maybe attack the c2 point we
just push it to c4
and this is a great great position for
for white there's really not
much black can do about this and even if
you try something like knight c5 then b4
comes and then
white is just you know all over the
board this is
unplayable for black so instead we have
queen to b8 here this is the
most played move here or rather the only
move uh that is
uh being played here and now uh you
don't really have to worry about any
knights the a5 ideas
we just played bishop to d8 and we're
going to eliminate it this knight from
here so
the queen makes room for the bishop and
also you will have support in the future
for playing b5
so here king the h1 always a useful move
a nice prophylactic idea getting the
king away from this
huge diagonal and now bishop the d8
so this bishop is now very nicely placed
although it kind of
disconnects the black rooks uh you'll
see that
in in this particular setup it's very
useful in this
next move that comes is a new move for
both uh
lekko and nipple uh because nepal
already had the disposition uh two years
prior to this game in 2014 nipple had it
against even charity
uh and charick played c4 here and he was
able to win that game but for this game
leko plays
f4 and it is now a new completely new
move
so already as a move 15 we have a
completely new game but also
a game that has never been repeated
since
so here f4 and now rook to e8
developing the rook adding a defender to
that e5 square
and now c4 makes sense you have to
cement this d5 pawn in but now comes
nepo's idea when he played queen to b8
b5
uh you want to attack the base of the
pawn chain and then weaken the d5 pawn
so here we have f captures an e5 and now
knight captures an e5 you do not want to
play pawn captures then you allow c5 and
then
this is just uh amazing for white you
you do not want to allow this so instead
after f captures an e5 we have knight
captures on e5 and now c captures on b5
uh we have eight captures and now knight
to d4
now the knight can come to c6 at some
point and could be
could be a very very nice idea and the
problem here is that uh
well uh lekko still has the bishop pair
he has a two to one advantage on the
queen side
uh but the bishop pair is uh far from
being fully operational and those
knights are
are looking pretty great and also nipple
just plays knight to c4 this is now a
beautiful night and he's attacking the
queen
and the bishop the bishop is attacked
twice so you have to eliminate it this
night so
uh leko forced to give up one of his
bishops so bishop captures
the b captures and now bishop to g1
you do not want this bishop constantly
hanging here
on e3 so bishop to g1 this is an
excellent defending piece as it regards
the h2 square and also you know
if even if the queen and the rook moves
you will never have to worry about some
smuttered mates here because the bishop
will also be guarding the f2 square
maybe also something to consider so here
queen to b7
developing the queen now attacking the
pawn here and now
what do you play here this is the
question uh so the question is
with do you go knights to c6 or not the
problem is
if you go knight to c6 then you allow
this knight the e4 idea
attacking the queen here and now for
example knight capture 78 attacking
black's queen
rook a capture 78 and now queen to d4
uh it's uh it's a fine position for both
white and black but black has
absolutely no problems here you can play
rook to c8 to defend your pawn or you
could go rook to b8 maybe to
put more pressure on the b to pawn a lot
of ways to play this and even though
this is not spectacular for white it's
it's actually pretty great for white uh
however
lekko did not go for that after queen to
b7 lekko played queen to c2 he
immediately put pressure on the
on the c4 pawn uh and he said all right
now you could uh definitely capture this
pawn with the queen you could capture it
with the knight uh
i don't care but he missed one a very
important
move uh that will uh haunt him for the
rest of the game maybe even longer so
feel free to pause the video here
and try to find this move like i missed
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on another
grabbing the pawn
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's knight to e4
uh it's not terrible to grab the pawn
but knight to e4
is just a beautiful move uh we're gonna
discuss that but
the problem is after something like
queen captures on d5 rook a to d1 and
then you might have problems along the d
file in the long run could be okay but
uh it's
uh much less directed than what nipple
played this knight the e4 move
now the problem is the c4 pawn is
defended by a tactic if you capture just
knight to the two wins that wins the
exchange
the queen and the rook are under attack
so you can't do this after knight the e4
lekko brought his rook to e1 now pinning
the knight and also attacking it twice
the knight is now attacked twice you
cannot move it because the rook would
hang
so here queen captures on the e4 by
nipple and
now what do you play here the knight is
now nicely defended the pawn is nicely
defended
but this was lekko's idea rook to f5
now the queen can't really move anywhere
or rather there's only one square the b7
square
if you move the queen anywhere uh from
that uh from this diagonal then the
knight will fall as the rook and queen
are still attacking it so
queen to b7 and now lekko brings the
rook over to b5 attacking the queen once
again and again only one move for nepo
that is queen to e7 defending the knight
twice
and again what do you play here uh well
uh
there there is really not all that much
you can uh
what what could you play here for
example if you go for something like
queen captures on c4
knight f2 check and now you really done
it bishop captures an f2
queen captures any one with check and
what do you play here
not much for you to play if the queen is
captured then just rook captures here
queen to f1 and rook captures is
checkmate so nothing nothing really
works out here
so after this queen the e7 move leica
realized okay uh
we can't do do it just yet we'll play
we're going to play rook to f1 add
another defender to the f2 square
this rook might be useful later on in
the future and i'm still attacking the
c4 pawn i'm attacking the h5 pawn so
it's really not a problem
but nipple just said nope uh i'm just
going to play g6 and you're not really
attacking anything because if you
capture my c4 pawn
the knight the d2 fork is still is still
here this is uh
you can't play this so after g6 we have
knights to f3
uh and now what do you play here uh well
now nepal just defends it with queen to
e6 the pawn is now nicely defended
and lego says all right i'm gonna kick
away the queen with knight to d4 but
first let's play
a4 the pawn is now hanging so let's push
it to a4
then we can maybe start pushing it to a5
and so on uh but we want to defend it
before
chasing away the black queen so here uh
nepal says
but this game was never about that pawn
you
you're more than welcome to grab that
pawn i'm just gonna push h4
here and now what are you gonna do how
do you stop uh
stop my pawn from being pushed to h3 you
could
uh play something like h3 but knight g3
check picks up the rook uh not really
not really happening there are already
too many holes uh
in white king's camp so here knight to
d4
chasing away the queen queen d7 and now
lekko finally
wins the back his pawn but like i said
uh this game was never about that pawn
and nipple now pushes
h3 and now what do you play here
uh well it's uh it's a very ugly
position the material on the board is
completely equal but that h pawn uh
that's that's a problem you could just
capture it and say i don't care let's
just play this but unless you have the
the like the soul of silicon you do not
play such a move
so instead after h3 we have rook to f4
uh by by lako uh getting that uh
rook uh into the attack now putting
pressure on the knight
and also maybe it can be used uh also
also for attack in the future maybe you
could also play something like g
for to guard the g4 square so it's a
it's a very nice
uh a nice active move but nepo just
brings the
the knight over to c5 now with a double
attack on the a4 pawn
so lekko defends it we have b3 and only
now
h captures on g2 with check he was not
in a rush to grab this pawn
a king captures and now rook the c8
putting some pressure on this queen now
ideas like just moving the knight
opening
up a discovery are possible so queen
back to f1 and now uh
finally this bishop that was resting
here for for the entire game
joins the action with bishop to g5 so
the rook has to move we have rook to f3
and only now
knight to e4 again an excellent score
for the knight and
ideas like knights the d2 are coming
with a double attack here on the rook
and on the queen
also for the moment defends the bishop
on g5 so so there's that so here we have
rook to d3
uh not allowing this uh not allowing
this fork and
now uh queen to g for with check you
can't really prevent queen to g for
check
the knight just covers f3 and g3 and
there's no
uh there's no defending this so here
like i said rook to d3 but now
queen to g for check king the h1 and now
this bishop shines once again the c1
square is covered
rook to c1 so what do you play here
there is only one good square otherwise
you're getting checkmated that's queen
to g2
and now of course you don't trade queens
you just play queen to h4
uh grab control of the f2 square and now
knight whoops uh
knights the f2 is coming so the knight
to f2 if this lands that's
just game over the bishop is pinned of
course will not be able to move so
rook the f3 guarding the f2 square once
again
but now comes uh bishop to e3 by nippo
uh you could also play this uh
differently for example a very nice idea
is just
knight to d2 this just creates absolute
madness on the board but uh
you know if a simpler way works uh often
in chess
we use that one we don't want to over
calculate and then blunder
but knight to d2 i will show it because
it's just uh really awesome
so we start by giving up this bishop on
g5
uh rook captures on g5 now we captured
the
bishop on g1 king captures and now rook
to e1 with
check that was the whole point rook to
f1 now we eliminated but not uh before
we grab this free knight queen captures
on d4 with
check rook h1 now rook captures an f1
with check and that's it queen captures
knight captures and this is a game over
uh however nippo did not want to over
calculate he played bishop to
e3 and it works just as just as nicely
so what what's the idea here uh well
you've added another attacker to the
bishop here and the problem is if the
bishop is captured
then we again get this knight to f2
check and
that's it there's really nothing to play
here you have to give up the queen
and that's it checkmate is being
threatened yes you will okay you can
give up the rook here king g7
and then rook g5 we defend checkmate but
now queen captures on d4 and this is
just completely winning for black the
material is
uh well not even important here so
instead after bishop to e3 we have
knights the e2 by lekko
defending the bishop one more time but
now comes
knight to f2 with check that was the
point of bishop to e3
uh we have rook captures and now bishop
captures an f2
now what do you play here uh rook
captures knight is coming so you really
don't have a good move here you have to
play something knight captures on c1 was
played
but now bishop captures on g1 and
even after all this madness the material
on the board is completely equal
but there is no good move for laco here
problem is the bishop cannot be captured
if the
if the king captures it then rook the e1
check the f2 square is covered
there are no moves here you have to give
up the queen and that's it
uh you don't even have to capture the
queen right away you could play some
like queen g4 check
nicely connect with the knight uh now if
you go here this is just checkmate so
you have to go here
and then after captures captures queen
d1 check we're going to pick up the
knight as well and again this is
completely winning
so after bishop captures in g1 we have
queen to g3
[Music]
queen capture simply loses to rook to e1
that's uh
self-explanatory uh so instead a queen
to g3
like i said the material on the board is
completely equal so why not just trade
queens and start pushing those past
pawns
but here comes queen to d4 now
uh you cannot pick up the bishop with
the king but you can pick it up with the
queen
and although this is the only reasonable
move it it
doesn't even help leko lekko played it
because there's nothing better he played
queen captures on g1
but now comes queen to d2 the threat is
now rook to e1
that just wins the game on the spot so
knight to d3
guarding the e1 square sacrificing or
rather giving back the piece
to survive the attack nipple picks it up
and then now rook to g5
uh one last attempt because you don't
really have a good move here you can
start pushing the pawns and
well uh queen to d2 followed by rook the
e1 is coming so you
you you really don't have any such
resources
left so rook the g5 this is one last
attempt a sneaky attempt by leko i did
not expect lego to be such a sneaky guy
uh but he is he's hoping for queen to d2
and then
uh rook to e1 and then if the queen
leaves the defense of the g6
pawn then he can just sacrifice the rook
here and he has a very nice perpetual
because now the rook has to be defended
and then we just not that obviously then
we just go queen here check go back here
check go back here and then it's a
draw by perpetual checking so instead
after work to g5
nepo said no this is not a problem i
just play rook to e2
and it was in this position on mu 46
that peter leko resigned the game
and this amazing victory was achieved by
ian niponnishi who didn't
only win this game but he also won the
entire tournament uh just so i don't
forget
uh here are the standings or rather here
are the standings
you can see that uh nipple won the
tournament one full point ahead of
pentagram
uh and then we have a lot of very strong
players dingling
vastly when chook peter leko uh ho ifan
and van gaal
so really really incredible stuff uh but
yeah
uh this is uh here you resign because
there's uh
not much you can play i mean there are
no moves this is still guarded if you
for example start pushing that
pass pawn just queen to e4 check and
that's it uh the the g2 square is
guarded
if you play queen here then rook to e1
is checkmate and if you defend with the
rook it's not much better
than just rook the one we win the queen
that's it
uh so really really amazing game as you
guys
requested you wanted to check out some
of nepal's game so we're going to check
out
some of the some of the well
brilliancies as like i said
just beating peter likewise the
brilliancy in itself beating him in in a
great style such as this one is
you know out of this world so hope you
guys enjoyed that
uh we're going to check up some other
games from nepal do
share you know feel free to use hashtag
suggestion to suggest your favorite ones
we're going to
uh check it out and cover them uh and
yeah i would like to thank frederick
karaher
todd morissette johnny's penises and
nathaniel rubin and joseph myers for
your contribution thank you a lot i
really appreciate it
i would also like to wish gideon all the
best with his bar mitzvah this saturday
hope
everything goes well there also and as
usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here thank you for watching and i will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
the morphe saga checking up on your
wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day